so Becky you won the first ever woman's
Main Event in Wrestlemania history yes
Becky Lynch is the sentimental favorite
as she marches to the ring tonight to
take on Charlotte Flair and Ronda Rousey
for people who are kind of maybe being
introduced what what does that mean to
you and and how special is that I think
any any wrestler their ambition is
always to be main event for Wrestlemania
and I'm for 35 years it was seen as
impossible Beyond a pipe dream that a
woman was going to Main Event
WrestleMania and so I wanted to Main
Event WrestleMania but I didn't want
I didn't want to Main Event WrestleMania
on a token gesture as in like oh look
now we're giving the women a shot to
Main Event WrestleMania no I wanted to
be the main event because it was the
hottest story and that there was no
other story that could follow it and I
feel like I feel like we got there and I
feel like it was it was the proper main
event and um yeah it's one of my biggest
accomplishments
[Applause]
Seth what goes through your mind when
you see your lady Main Event
WrestleMania oh pure jealousy
no she she mentioned you know anybody in
our profession their goal I mean my goal
since I was four years old is to Main
Event WrestleMania and to see her be
able to do that uh and really just smash
through any expectations or any
boundaries limitations whatever you want
to call it that have ever been set for
women is pretty special it was awesome
to be a part of the show awesome to be
able to be there and support her and
watch her in that moment and Becky right
of the floor it's just it was a
groundbreaker it set the tone for the
future of of females in our Sport and so
you know it's one of those things that
our daughter will look at at some point
in her life and hopefully it will be an
example to her that she can do anything
she sets her mind to oh it's amazing I
know you were joking when you said
jealousy but I'm just what how do you do
it how do you guys feel like you were
able to like overcome that navigate that
it was hard for me at first to be honest
with you I think because the business is
so me first it's very difficult to put
somebody else on the same level as you
even when it's your significant other
and so it was it was a huge insecurity
of mine and it really took some some
pushing and pulling to to get me to a
different place mentally where I I was
as supportive of her as I was of myself
and the jealousy wasn't you know oh
overwhelming but I mean I think it goes
both ways I mean it's just it's you know
in the business kind of Ebbs and flows
as well so sometimes you're up sometimes
you're both up sometimes wanting is down
and it's just about trying to be there
for each other support each other and be
happy uh for each other's success you
know we're a team and so we got to be we
gotta treat it that way but like I said
it's just it's not in the nature of pro
wrestling to treat it as a team sport
it's individual you know you've spent
all these years working on you and your
thing and your act and so to support a
fellow competitor just feels against
nature yeah but you know when it's
someone you love and it's someone you
want to see happy and when you see them
in pain it's the worst thing in the
world it makes it a lot easier to want
to be there for them so it certainly was
a difficult task for me she was much
better than I was
no no no no no no no because it does
like you said it Ebbs and flows and I
think the important thing to do is be
honest and and and vulnerable in in
those insecurities and also let them
know that it's
it's not you it's me it's me I can't
handle this right now
and I think that's uh that's been a big
help and um and then yeah just just
trying to be happy you know and knowing
that just because somebody's somebody's
up and somebody's not as quite quite as
up at all it all just comes around we're
all just going up together you know one
one final thing I add to that is is as
difficult as it can be when you start to
kind of compare
it is the best because no one really
understands what we do except for us our
lifestyle and our industry is so wild
and out there I mean we're just crazy
circus folk you know traveling the world
doing this professional wrestling Sports
entertainment thing and to have someone
uh with you every single day to be able
to do this with your best friend makes
it so much easier you get that
understanding and to understand where
the other person is coming from all the
time really helps you kind of put
everything together
what was that experience like oh it's
brilliant I was brilliant to uh take on
the role of an icon yeah
by the way oh yeah that was nice I
wanted to do her justice for the the
woman that she is but also what she's
done for our industry and how she helped
bring wrestling into the mainstream with
that rock and wrestling connection so it
was really important that I could do her
justice and not offend any New Yorkers
and get that voice right and the octaves
were a little bit hard but as we can see
I've got range I can be the Batman
voices yeah
can be Cindy it can do it all
exfoliating which with the voice
you guys did this kind of jokery promo
what went into this it was so fun we did
a lot of work on the voice yeah yeah
yeah it was hard for me to get that
registered and the man yeah there there
it is that's natural I've seen a lot of
comments of people being like that's to
play The Joker because of your laugh
I'm curious if that yeah was that
happening before this promo yeah no the
laugh has always existed I don't know
where it came from it's just uh it was a
so good yeah just one of those things
it's crazy yeah yeah yeah I don't know
those are some big shoes to fill ah
no there's so many good portrayals of
the Joker that's what I'm saying that's
a lot they're all they're all bangers
I'm scared to follow well you're Ledger
you give him Jack Nicholson walking
Phoenix that's a lot those are some some
Hall of Famers man those are some
special cats I don't know I don't know I
can dance the dance I don't know if I
can walk the walk I got the purple suit
on and everything oh yeah yeah yeah very
much so very Ode to Jack uh Jack
Nicholson yeah well Becky I really want
to see you in some kind of superhero
film and there was like this rumor that
you shot something for eternals is that
true can I see I don't know if I can say
that that's true I suppose it's true
it's true I just don't know if I can say
that it's you yeah it's true uh yeah
yeah uh can I say that I don't know I
don't know I mean I feel like it's like
it is gone it is gone but we don't know
about sequels yeah
oh I want to see it I want to know more
but so yeah
I know somebody comes through the door I
don't know what takes you out in
shackles I don't know
some Galactic prison somewhere Star-Lord
watching over here
I don't know I don't know I don't know
what I can say there I can't stop
thinking about WrestleMania how are we
feeling about this weekend get them
ready feeling ready feeling ready just
got her belt I came dressed like a
freaking Flamenco downtown I'm ready
yeah it's Hollywood baby it's uh the
biggest WrestleMania of all time it's
gonna be huge two nights it's it's uh
we're ready I mean we're dressed for the
occasion so yeah it's good it's gonna be
a party yeah y'all live here
yeah
so we'll kind of be in your town and not
be traveling around
to be able to go and do Wrestlemania
Wrestlemania Sophie stadium and then
come home and sleep in our own bed
just that stop the lights don't get any
better than that and having to be able
you know a home base to be able to just
get there and be grounded it's very nice
and also not bring the baby on another
plane
so very nice how old is Shane two two
and a half so you you guys travel with
her all the time yeah yep yep everywhere
we go where what's your password yeah
it's pretty crazy probably gonna need
another one a couple of months is that
typical like do other
families bring their kids along or you
guys I think we started the trend yeah
we started the trend and now there's a
few more jumping on the on the bandwagon
um but it's great it's great you get the
best boat towards for me the kids like
oh yeah I grew up with the in the
wrestling world I hope I hope that she
has a positive spin on it
my concern is she goes the other
direction with it and we get blamed for
everything this is why my life is a mess
I think that's inevitable no matter what
to be fair at least we'll have some good
pictures yeah so you both have matches
day one WrestleMania Seth let's start
with you you're going up against Logan
Paul
who's landed this one lucky punch twice
yeah uh where's your head at going into
this weekend uh you know pretty good my
track record at WrestleMania is strong I
will say I think I'm going into my 10th
WrestleMania now
um I've had a lot of incredible moments
at WrestleMania I expect to add Logan
Paul to that list and look the the lucky
punches were
they were cheap shots let's be honest it
wasn't just mono mono it wasn't just
one-on-one it wasn't in the middle of a
match it was a brawl there was somebody
pulling me off I'm not making any
excuses the kid's got a hell of a right
hand drop me a couple times but
WrestleMania is going to be different
when it's Bell to bell inside that
squared Circle nobody's better than me
so I'm gonna raise his level and then
I'm going to beat him do you think Logan
Paul's going to stick around you know
what I don't know he's an interesting
cat you know he's got he's got his hand
and a lot of a lot of different things
out there
um we'll see I I I'm gonna beat him I
might beat him bad enough that he
doesn't want to stick around I don't
know we'll see let's see where his
mind's at he's a young kid bright future
ahead of him whatever he wants to do in
life
um if he wants to stick around and be a
part of WWE
um we'll see we'll see if he's if he's
ready to pass the real test so how about
three versus u3 at Wrestlemania
Becky the build up to this six woman
match with damage control yes has been
excellent
um where are you at going into this
weekend it's been going on since since
SummerSlam since they took out my
shoulder since they left me not being
able to take care of my kid when he was
off on the road I had to call in help I
wasn't able to pick her up
um and so when somebody's doing
something like that to you you think of
all the ways you're going to destroy
them once you get back on your feet so
now
of WrestleMania with myself leader and
Trish Stratus all three of us three
Legends going in there together it's got
to be the end it it ends this weekend
WrestleMania weekend rules I mean it's
just such a celebration of our industry
and you know people will say what they
want about it but I love it I just think
it's one of the coolest sort of forms of
entertainment there is there's just
nothing like it it combines all the
elements and uh it's a business that's
really given me everything that I have
in my life you know I grew up in a small
town a thousand people in rural Iowa and
now here we are sitting on the set of
entertainment tonight and with my
beautiful wife who I met through the
sport we were talking about our
beautiful daughter talking about the you
know biggest stadium in North America uh
and we're about to have this two-night
event and so really WrestleMania weekend
is just about celebrating this industry
that's given us all so much so I'm just
happy to be a part of it
I can't say anything better than that
foreign
[Music]